good morning Hank it's Monday I'm
wearing a suit made out of signatures
but I can't remember why please ignore
my crazy eyes they're crazy mmm
crazy I want to thank everybody for
participating in signing psychosis
because I know my fashion sense is
getting worse and worse as I get crazier
and crazier with the signatures but your
fashion sense is also getting worse
nerdfighteria and that makes me feel
better sometimes I just like to rub my
signatures do you think it could be the
sharpie chemicals maybe they're making
me you know crazy am I crazy or am I the
say mr. Singh in the room I'm the only
person in the room hold on I got to
acquire another person to test my sanity
Willie are you a dog or a man there's no
such thing as a mob what you are you
pick I realized I must free myself from
the tyranny of these signatures movie
magic can't cuz you know I'm under a lot
of stress right now mostly because of
the Tippie of signing let's go to the
Tippi odometer oh I made a mistake
it's not as wheely as I thought it was
gonna be so as you can see I only have
25,000 copies left to sign but a 25,000
is a lot of copies and B I don't have
any non-travel days left in which to
sign those books so I'm sort of freaking
out right now
like I want to quickly thank
nerdfighteria again for giving me the
world's first first world problem I
signed in fifty three hundred books
yesterday it took me about fourteen
hours I'm going to have to keep that
pace going on every non-travel day
between now and November 3rd in order to
finish I hope that I finish because
otherwise some of you will get unsigned
books and you will be very mad at me and
I will be mad at myself there will be a
lot of anger in the room sometimes when
I feel a lot of anxiety I just want to
like sound my barbaric yawp over the
rooftops of the world like yeah
Oh
Oh somebody got me a zombie unicorn Hank
wasn't that nice all right Hank we are
now at Holiday Park and people are
looking at me funny but I don't know why
I'm just a man in a suit with the zombie
unicorn hat filming himself
what else do you expect to see in a
public park on a Monday morning okay
Hank I need nerdfighters help
nerdfighters you have uncovered the
story of Ivan the terrible's terrible
library you have found the truth about
gussie manlove and now I need you to
explain to me the ruins so there are
these weird fake ruins in the middle of
a public park here in Indianapolis but
they've kind of become real ruins due to
decades of neglect so I'm hoping that by
using the combined research powers of
nerdfighteria we can figure out you know
what the heck Hank this would of course
be a great time to use your pants but
unfortunately your pants are still
broken sentences that don't make sense
out of context so we can use a format
the Ning or YouTube comments here but
I'm hoping that you guys can just help
me figure out what is this strange and
terrible beauty behind me Hank I'm going
to go back to signing but I will see you
on Wednesday
PS nerdfighters I will be reading from
The Fault in Our Stars in Indianapolis
on November 1st and I will also be at
the final beckoning of lovely event at
the bean in Chicago on November 11th
more info in the doobly-doo P I think I
know we're throwing around words like
crazy and psychosis and I also know that
lots of nerdfighters including this one
have struggled or are struggling with
mental illness so anyway I don't wanna
make fun of metal unless I want to make
fun of me alright that's all see you
tomorrow Wednesday god I'm so bad at
days